[Musique]
bienvenue dans PAP 2e partie si vous
nous rejoignez toujours avec Ludivine
rittory Maxime gueny qui nous accompagne
on a la joie d'accueillir aujourd'hui
olivier Delacroix sur ce plateau bonjour
Olivier Delacroix merci d'être avec nous
ce soir on a plein de choses à se dire
on a plein de questions à vous poser
évidemment Olivier Delacroix regarder
votre CV qui s'affiche à l'écran vous
avez fait tellement de choses vous
pouvez vous le savez c'est bon il y a
pas de fautes
[Applaudissements]
le principal voilà effectivement
dans les yeux d'Olivier bien sûr qu'on
connaît tous et la libre antenne on va
s'en parler sur sur Europe 1 parce que
là aussi vous avez beaucoup de
témoignages évidemment qui ne connaît
pas olivier Delacroix vous savez faire
parler les gens recueillir des
témoignages très forts des témoignages
sociétaux les gens se confient à eux
parfois sur des sujets extrêmement
difficiles et vous avez ce salon ce
talent justement de de pouvoir aider les
gens à se confier sur
sur un événement de vie sur une maladie
on va on va y revenir dans quelques
instants mais d'abord c'est une émission
immédiat ils viennent Delacroix j'ai
envie de vous poser la première question
vous regardez quoi à la télé alors moi
je regarde beaucoup de séries je suis
très comme voilà beaucoup de séries
beaucoup de séries américaines je suis
très serré narcos topboy sur Netflix
excellence
moments sont les dernières vraiment la
série qui m'a un gros consommateur de
série sur les plateformes et puis après
beaucoup de documentaires
et où finalement on retrouve un peu tout
toutes les chaînes
non pas trop je regarde ma copine julia
Vignali quand je peux depuis peu je
trouve qu'elle est formidable
l'après-midi je ne rate pas
non je me couche
je me couche très tard à quelle heure
vous je me couchais à 3h30 4h tous les
matins
chez moi mais vous savez le temps de
redescendre
c'est difficile d'aller se coucher après
donc vous coucher très très tard la nuit
et j'essaie de me refaire régulièrement
bon les chaînes d'infos je regarde pas
mal quand je me lève et puis complément
d'enquête
je dis investigation sont des j'essaie
de de tout le temps d'être de pas trop
prendre de retard voilà et les les
grandes soirées infrarouges de français
vision aussi où il y a quand même une
qualité de documentaire excellente donc
voilà
je suis pas très alors on parlait on va
parler d'une émission la robe de ma vie
c'est ça je vois que vous avez des
briques dans
un
vraiment pur exactement votre ami ça
vraiment il nous intéresse effectivement
ça on en parlera après effectivement la
robe de ma vie sur sur sister à moi
justement sur cette limontaine sur sur
Europe 1 vous avez beaucoup de
témoignages très forts notamment vous
avez eu le des témoignages sur des
personnes qui sont atteintes d'un
covidon par exemple d'un père qui
s'inquiète aussi pour la santé mentale
de de son fils comment d'abord comment
vous pas caster c'est pas le bon terme
mais comment vous arrivez à trouver
effectivement ces témoin et comment vous
vous y prenez pour les aider à être en
confiance et à pouvoir se confier parce
que c'est moi qui pose des questions
finalement
on se rend compte que vous vous posez en
une question il y en a trois quatre
alors
beaucoup de gens appellent cette libre
antenne parce qu'en 4 ans on a vraiment
gagné quand repeint a fait le pari de Me
de mettre sur cette libre antenne
c'était justement pour amener une touche
sociétale la libre antenne elle était
tradition finalement assez psy un psycho
donc moi j'ai élargi et donc voilà
covidon la santé mentale d'un d'un
enfant mais ça peut être une histoire
d'amour qui tourne mal ça peut être
le placement des enfants aussi bien que
des problèmes de voisinage il y a
beaucoup de gens qui m'appellent et ce
sont toujours des gens qui ont des
problèmes entre guillemets qui ont envie
de parler on a tous des problèmes mais
le principe de la libre antenne vous
demandez comment j'arrivais à gagner
leur confiance c'est l'écoute en fait
vous le savez ma chère Pascal nous
sommes dans un milieu où l'ego est un
peu plus surdimensionné et où de
nombreux confrères et concerts
il faut intervenir or je pense que
naturellement moi je parfois
c'est un de mes potes qui me dit ça
l'autre jour j'ai chronométré pendant 2
minutes 10 on t'a pas entendu intervenir
c'est énorme alors vous pouvez regarder
2 minutes vous dites 2 minutes c'est
rien mais en télé ou en radio c'est la
radio en 2010 bon ça passe mais il
écoute je pense que aujourd'hui on est
dans une société où beaucoup de
personnes ont l'impression de ne plus
être écouté entendu et donc du coup je
pense que depuis dans les jeux d'olivier
et puis ensuite avec la libre antenne
c'est cette confiance là que je gagne en
écoutant attentivement celles et ceux
qui veulent bien me parler et vous avez
le droit est-ce que on vous on vous met
des barrières c'est à dire ce que vous
avez le droit d'aborder tous les thèmes
est-ce que ça soit sur France 2 aussi
bien que sur
on ne m'a jamais
mis la moindre barrière non non je crois
je crois qu'il y a des thèmes c'est pas
très fédéral
non je pense que depuis le début je fais
preuve aussi de de
limite on n'est jamais dans le pathos on
n'est jamais d'envoyer le risque on est
et puis je protège beaucoup celles et
ceux qui me parlent parce que parfois la
confiance l'émotion les emmène plus loin
que ce qui est permis de raconter ou de
voir à la télé ou à la radio donc c'est
important de liberté
d'avoir cette en direct et puis la radio
est un média très vivant très instantané
et puis lorsqu'on va acheter sa baguette
de pain le lendemain dans les jeux
d'Olivier c'est pas la même que quand
vous êtes passé sur la libre antenne
lorsqu'on s'engage pour se raconter à la
télévision bon c'est un c'est un sacré
engagement quelle est la chose la plus
insolite que vous ayez eu à gérer en
direct pendant la libre antenne
une personne qui voulait mettre fin à
ses jours
ça m'est arrivé deux trois fois depuis
quatre ans et ce sont les je ne dirais
pas insolites mais les situations les
plus méfiantes compliquées à gérer ouais
sont les plus embarrassants
là vous avez une responsabilité parce
que vous êtes avec quelqu'un qui est
vraiment au bout et oui il faut bien
peser les mots d'emploi et essayer de
mais si quand même c'est moi qui vous le
dise parce que ce que vous arrivez à
faire on se dit les choses quand même
en tout cas j'ai fait en sorte que ces
personnes une fois qu'elle raccrochent
parce que l'engagement c'était qu'elle
me rappelle semaine après semaine nous
avons avec mon équipe de la liberté
parce qu'elle est très importante on a
réussi à établir un d'abord à peser les
mots ensuite à établir un contrat de
trouver des choses pour se raccrocher un
peu quoi voilà alors vous me disez tout
à l'heure pour repasser dans un tout
autre Regis c'est vrai que quand on
descend dans la rue acheter sa baguette
de pain le matin et qu'on a fait dans
les yeux d'Olivier la veille forcément
c'est pas la même c'est vrai que vous
êtes très identifiable notamment pardon
de changer de sujet mais grâce à vos
coiffures à vaudrait et vous vous êtes
confiés à ce sujet
vous la reprochez ça en télé d'avoir des
non jamais on vous a demandé de les
couper non non pas vraiment je pense
plutôt que
ça a été une gêne pour
à différents moments de ma carrière
certains patrons des programmes me
regarder avec une certaine terreur dans
dans les yeux mais pourquoi ça faisait
pas propre de mettre quelqu'un avec pas
propre c'est que je pense être aussi
propre que vous chez les laves non parce
que c'est la c'est juste que si vous
voulez ce milieu est tellement lisse et
tellement voilà il faut être bien
habillé il faut pas rien dépasser ah
d'accord on est trop passé
non mais c'est non non mais c'est vrai
c'est un choix cette coiffure
frisés mais que je ne peignais pas un
jour avec ma tante elle m'ont attrapé
j'avais 20 ans j'étais dans mon bain 18
ans peut-être même et puis elles m'ont
elles m'ont démêlé les cheveux mais
elles ont tellement abîmé ce jour-là que
je fasse je partais ensuite au Costa
Rica pendant deux mois et demi avec mon
frère et que surf tous les jours plus
soleil plus celles plus surf plus celles
plus soleil
ma mère m'a vu revenir avec ses Liam
elle a dû adoré elle a dit kiffer
j'aimais pas les cheveux frisés c'est
chiant les cheveux et en fait c'est
vraiment je le prends vraiment comme un
un don parce que elle ça pousse depuis
maintenant plus de 35 ans comme ça parce
qu'il y a plein de gens qui me disent
ouais mais tu fais des tourniquets enfin
voilà parce qu'il y a non je ne je ne
fais rien ça pousse vous voyez
normalement
et je défie un quelconque coiffeur de
dire qu'il m'a vu chez lui depuis 35 ans
ah vous êtes jamais allé chez le
coiffeur depuis 35 ans
c'est vrai que la particularité c'est
que une personne me voit une fois et
elle enregistre c'est un époque
présentateur de foot avec Canal+ qui me
disent c'est dingue je passe 20 fois
plus que toi à long terme et dans la rue
c'est toi qu'on reconnait donc c'est
j'ai une tronche particulière je ne sais
voilà c'est ce qui fait votre
spécificité Ludivine est-ce que vous
pensez justement que ça vous a fermé
beaucoup de portes d'être voilà un ovni
entre guillemets un ovni télévisuel
vraiment aujourd'hui
je suis tellement
comblé par la carrière que j'ai que si
ça m'a fermé les portes
je pense que j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir affirmer mes convictions dans ce
métier d'avoir eu aussi et je le dis
parce que c'est super important
depuis maintenant plus de 5 ans des
patrons et avant eux mais affronter les
visions qui ont protégé dans les jeux
d'oliviers qui m'ont protégé qui ont
continué ça fait 12 ans maintenant que
ce programme existe il y a une
conviction de ma part qui a été appuyée
par mes boss à France Télévisions donc
du coup voilà entre la libre antenne
Europe 1 et dans les yeux d'Olivier
croyez moi je suis très occupé et donc
du coup si des portes se sont fermés à
cause de ça
voilà ça vous va très bien ça va très
bien me changer rien dites-moi je
voudrais qu'on revienne en parler de
l'amour et dans le pré tout à l'heure
effectivement qui arrivait encore en
tête hier vous avez des coups de gueule
Olivier vous dites que vous pensez
notamment sur sur ce programme on va
voir ce que vous aviez déclaré et on va
voir ce que vous en pensez aujourd'hui
vous vous ça va s'afficher sur votre
écran je n'aime pas du tout cette
émission je sens que tout est fou dans
cette émission pour moi l'Amour est dans
le pré c'est parti de ces émissions que
qui se jouent des sentiments et des
émotions est-ce que vous pensez toujours
ça alors d'abord je voudrais vous dire
une chose c'est que je regrette
profondément
de manière instantanée d'avoir dit ce
que je pensais
de ne pas dire que vous pensez quand
même parce que c'est avec un de vos
collaborateurs
première question je vous avoue en plus
que comme je suis quelqu'un de très
spontané de très franc je me prépare pas
et puis il y a des règles dans ce milieu
et une des règles c'est pas de balancer
sur les petits copains et les petites
copines vous avez le droit de de vous je
trouve Karine Le Marchand extrêmement
doué pour ce qu'elle fait extrêmement
intelligente et mais mes mots ont
dépassé ma pensée je lui en ai fait mes
excuses d'ailleurs elle n'a pas répondu
bon
mais voilà je regarde jamais l'amour est
dans le pré je m'en fous en fait
vous dites quoi de l'émission voilà les
gens regardent ce qu'ils veulent je pars
du principe aujourd'hui que quand un
programme trouve son public on doit le
respecter et j'ai eu tort de de voilà de
de dire ça mais je le regrette et je
l'ai dit avec le droit mais vous avez le
droit et bon Karine
le programme oui mais vous savez comment
c'est ça a été repris le soir notamment
chez Cyril Karine c'est vexé elle a
appelé enfin ça a pris la mayonnaise moi
le lendemain j'étais au salon de
l'agriculture tout le monde me regardait
comme
je regrette
voilà on balance pas et et ça fait
partie des choses qui m'ont appris aussi
de pas toujours dire la vérité de pas
toujours dire ce que vous pensez ça ce
que vous dire Olivier parce que j'ai
toujours la vérité moi
si je sais moi malheureusement c'est une
très mauvaise honte si vous saviez je me
fais avoir à tous les coups non je sais
pas faire ça juste aussi une petite
déclaration que c'est que vous avez
faite à propos de l'émission Ça commence
aujourd'hui sur France 2 vous aviez dit
je pense que Faustine Bollaert c'est un
très bon boulot elle a de bonnes
audiences elle a remonté des après-midi
de France 2 On témoignant 7 minutes je
pense que quand même qu'on survole les
choses oui évidemment c'est pas le même
format que vous alors
une déclaration où il faut peser chaque
mot en fait c'est pas du tout c'est pas
exactement cette phrase elle a été
sortie d'un contexte général dans lequel
le journaliste me disait que dans les
yeux d'olivier
qu'on traite chaque histoire 24 à 26
minutes je disais et d'ailleurs je
parlais aussi bien de l'émission de
Faustine que celle de Cyril ou à
l'époque puisque ça remonte à quelques
années ça où on prenait moins de temps
pour ces histoires
j'ai emprunté le mot survoler encore une
fois peut-être ne dépasse pas le terme
le plus précis mais encore une fois je
crois que il y a rien à redire sur le
talent de Faustine sa capacité à écouter
il y a souvent des comparaisons entre
nous parce que je crois qu'elle a ce
talent d'écoute c'est hypersensibilité
l'important je vais vous dire c'est que
Faustine c'est ce que je pense d'elle et
le jour où c'est ce journaliste belge me
titiller sur sur Faustine ensuite
c'était sur Cyril ensuite se car il ne
marchant bon voilà
il vous adore alors il me disait
Delacroix je l'adore c'est vrai je vous
promets
on était tous les deux sur France 4 au
tout début et tous les deux on est sorti
de la même façon
hé regarde Olivier ce que vous avez dit
Cyril Hanouna très doué dans ce qu'il
fait si on veut se renseigner sur la oui
c'est vrai c'est très vrai ce que vous
dites sur la température de la société
vous pouvez savoir ce qui se passe grâce
à TPMP c'est très libre et populaire
c'est une émission qui est assez typique
dans le paysage audiovisuel si on veut
je pense que dans notre métier de
journaliste
si on veut être le plus juste possible
dans notre quête de la vérité de la
réalité parce que c'est ce qu'on nous
apprend à l'école de journalisme c'est
ce que nous apprend à aller chercher la
réalité la ramener vraiment il faut être
au courant des choses et pour être au
courant des choses il faut regarder
aussi bien cnews que BFM que le journal
de TF1 et celui de France Télévisions il
faut regarder c'est dans l'air c'est à
vous aussi bien que Touche pas à mon
poste je pense qu'il faut connaître
toutes les tendances et être au courant
de ce dont on parle et de qui on parle
or j'essaie de me de me tenir au courant
parce que c'est mon métier et que que
oui encore une fois TPMP Cyril Hanouna
ne rencontrerez pas cette popularité et
ce public s'il y avait pas quelque chose
de puissant dedans il y a quelque chose
de puissant lui aussi c'est ce que je
pense je sais ce qu'ils pensent de moi
et voilà merci beaucoup et encore une
fois vous savez encore une fois dans ce
milieu voilà c'est pas toujours les plus
les plus gentils et les plus
sympas
mais Cyril en même temps voilà quand il
a quelque chose à dire comme moi il le
dit et donc du coup on n'est pas
beaucoup sauf que lui sauf que lui quand
il la ramène il y a pas grand monde qui
l'emmerde tandis que moi
on en parle encore trois ans après
c'est une bonne guerre non juste mais
non demande des explications c'est
intéressant d'avoir votre regard
et sur Sud Radio alors justement tiens
vous vous disiez vous regardez beaucoup
des chaînes info vous avez poussé ah bah
ouais bon vous êtes vous pouvez venir
pas allé chercher bien loin s'il vous
plaît
la veille je vois il y a de Moix appeler
presque au suicide est-ce que vous
pensez sincèrement
je crois enfin
ce mec devrait se suicider voilà mais
bon j'ai vu le traitement d'une affaire
ou un gars bien évidemment
commet une horreur
et et il sait qu'il a commis l'horreur
il est sans doute complètement au fond
du trou et pendant 10 jours j'entends
mais comme si chacun et chacune s'essuie
les pieds sur la tronche de Pierre
Palmade un moment assud radium m'a
demandé ce que j'en pensais et j'ai dit
ouais j'ai dit stop il est peut-être
bien de passer à autre chose quoi ça
fait 10 jours qu'on répète les mêmes
choses en boucle j'ai pas pris la
défense je ne le connais pas Pierre
Palmade le traitement qui a été fait
l'acharnement c'était de l'acharnement
sur quelqu'un qui est dès qu'il a
percuté cette voiture était mort déjà
médiatiquement
sociétalement parlant et oui
l'acharnement m'a profondément gêné et
je vais vous je vais vous dire quelque
chose après mon passage à Sud radio BFM
télé m'a demandé de venir pour répéter
ce que j'avais dit je suis venu sur BFM
et si vous saviez le nombre de SMS que
j'ai reçu me remercient de enfin un peu
d'humanité dans dans ce traitement voilà
je me souviens pas qu'il y a eu beaucoup
de gens pour dire STOP voilà c'est bon
là
les chaînes devraient donc s'abstenir au
strict minimum je ne dis pas qu'il faut
s'abstenir mais on a traité un fait
divers dramatique bien évidemment avec
une célébrité
est-ce que est-ce qu'il nécessaire de
que ça soit la ligne éditoriale
notamment d'une chaîne pendant presque
dix jours vous avez vu les audiences
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que les
gens sont intéressés par autre chose oui
mais les audiences
il y a de la dignité à avoir dans notre
métier est-ce que quand on fait le
métier de journaliste on est là pour
informer les gens et pour pendant que
Pierre Palmade percuter cette voiture et
et et tuer un bébé détruisez le des
sentiers d'une famille il y a des gens
qui continuaient à prendre des bateaux
pour traverser la Méditerranée il y
avait la guerre en Ukraine il y avait
encore tout un tas de choses qui se
passaient le monde ne sait pas arrêter
de tourner le jour où Pierre Palmade a
fait assez la connerie de sa vie voilà
j'ai voulu dire un moment stop c'est une
manière d'abrutir les gens comprenez de
de tout le temps le rabâcher et puis moi
je vais vous dire ce qui me gênait
c'était que d'un seul coup un puissant
un mec qui avait du succès de l'argent
d'un seul coup il était à terre voilà et
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce que je fais
allé dire je suis juste à lui dire
arrêtez de vous essuyer vos pompes sur
ce mec là c'est bon et ça vaut
maintenant encore aujourd'hui